foreign
although the terms crypto coin crypto
token and cryptocurrency are frequently
used interchangeably they don't mean the
same thing although both coins and
tokens employ blockchain technology
there are some key distinctions between
the two and that is what I'm going to
talk about in this video hey everyone
welcome to this new coin versus token
video that will cover some major
differences between these two so let's
start the journey but before that please
do subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more such interesting topics but before
getting to the comparison of crypto
coins and tokens let me give a quick
introduction to what is a digital asset
this will help you understand the
difference between crypto coins and
tokens better broadly speaking a digital
asset is a non-tangible asset that is
created exchanged and kept in a digital
format by this definition
cryptocurrencies and crypto tokens are
considered digital Assets in the context
of blockchains since both
cryptocurrencies and tokens are digital
assets on blockchains the terms are
frequently used synonymously but they
are not similar there are multiple
parameters where they differ from each
other on multiple levels and that's what
we will cover moving forward in this
video so let me take you through the
comparison parameters based on which we
will compare crypto coins and tokens
first is definition cryptocurrencies
have their own unique blockchain BTC is
the currency used in the Bitcoin
blockchain ethereum has eth on its
blockchain similar to traditional
currencies the main purpose of these
currency coins is to serve as a form of
wealth storage and a medium of exchange
for this reason cryptocurrency is
another name for cryptocurrency coins
although they are created utilizing
blockchain technology unlike
cryptocurrency currencies crypto tokens
are not native to a blockchain while
cryptocurrency coin imitate conventional
money crypto tokens behave more like
assets or even Deeds a crypto token may
serve as a proxy for ownership the next
parameter that will be measured is
Supply if getting your learning started
is half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit skillup by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know more
the way they are created mining is used
to create crypto coins in most cases
cryptocurrencies are either mined using
a proof of work or pow or a proof of
stake POS consensus mechanism tokens
unlike cryptocurrencies are generalized
and distributed by the project developer
rather than being mined tokens Can Be
utilized in a plethora of ways once they
are in the possession of buyers now
talking about fees or gas when
transferring a cryptocurrency
transaction fees or gas are cheaper
however when transferring tokens they
are more expensive when transferring
tokens you still require some
cryptocurrency in the same account
because fees are always paid for in
cryptocurrencies now moving on to the
next parameter purpose what are they
used for or what they serve crypto coins
are designed to work in the same way as
paper money and metal coins meaning they
can can be used for many of the things
normally used with US dollars or Euros
including storing value exchanging for
other currencies paying for goods and
services transferring to others and so
forth whereas most crypto tokens are
made to be utilized in dapps or
blockchain based projects crypto tokens
Can represent ownership in a dow a
digital product or nft or even a
tangible item crypto tokens are similar
to currencies in that they may be
purchased sold and exchanged but are not
utilized as a means of exchange to put
it another way crypto coins are more
like dollars and cents whereas crypto
tokens are more like coupons or vouchers
and the last parameter that will be
measured is types choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
Plus hours of video content for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
the variation of crypto coins or tokens
present in the crypto Market some of the
popular crypto coins are Bitcoin the
first and most well-known crypto coin in
the world ethereum implements smart
contracts and is the home to thousands
of blockchain projects and nfts cardano
an open source and decentralized
blockchain platform that is one of the
first to run on a POS consensus and many
more in crypto tokens some of the
popular tokens are filecoin and rweave
allow users to pay with their utility
tokens for the right to store data on
their decentralized Network maximizing
the potential of cloud storage axi
Infinity one of the best known play to
earn on the market and features a
utility token called Smooth love potions
Chronos a utility token for the
crypto.com ecosystem and there are many
more tokens available in the crypto
ecosystem now the decision of whether to
purchase coins or tokens greatly depends
upon the holder's intentions well that
was all about crypto versus token and if
you found this video interesting and
informative then please do like this
video And subscribe to our YouTube
channel for more interesting videos and
updates like this also if you have any
questions regarding this video please
feel free to ask away in our comments
section our team will reach out to you
as soon as possible thank you and keep
learning
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here